we don't come to questions the Prime
Minister Tim Lawton
Mr Speaker
UK will continue to work to end the
Bloodshed in Sudan and support a
democratic government we have begun a
large-scale evacuation of British
Nationals and I pay tribute to all those
carrying out this complex operation Mr
Speaker this morning I had meetings with
the ministerial colleagues and others in
addition to my duties in this house I
shall have further such meetings later
today
Mr Speaker yesterday the opposition
grabbed a crude headline about boys to
have respect for women an important
issue I'm sure that prime minister will
agree
but given that the leader of the
opposition apparently doesn't know what
a woman is
that he won't stand up to defend women
in his own party
[Applause]
this when he was in charge as DPP does
my right honorable friend think that the
labor party are in any position to teach
anyone about respect for women and is
the irony dead
right right
I'm going to bring the play soon but in
furnace he's a responsibility for the
answer to the opposition but prime
minister Mr Speaker my uh honorable
friend is absolutely right the leader of
the the leader of the opposition's
record on women is questionable at best
Mr Speaker and before and before Labor
do start preaching about this issue they
should work out the answer to one very
simple question I'm certain what a woman
is is he
[Applause]
Safeguard can I join the prime minister
in paying tribute to the brave British
Personnel involved in the evacuation
effort from Sudan
the government must do everything in its
power to urgently evacuate UK Nationals
still trapped in Sudan
Mr Speaker yesterday George Osborne said
that the Tory party's handling of the
economy makes them Vandals
he's right isn't he
[Applause]
well I
stir Mr Speaker while we're in the
business of quoting former chancellors
and Shadow chancellors I don't know if
he saw the remarks from a former labor
Shadow Chancellor yesterday who said our
country had faced four Once in a century
shocked threats to our economy and the
fact that we've come through it is a
Triumph Mr Speaker
well that former Chancellor not only
said there were a bunch of Tory vandals
he also said there was a self-induced
financial crisis on the country that's
those vandals and they like to pretend
that it was all just one week of Madness
last Autumn but the truth is it's been
13 years of failure
real wages the money in people's pockets
have fallen by sixteen hundred pounds
per household sixteen hundred pounds the
prime minister's response to impose 24
Tory tax rises in three years 24. how on
Earth does he think his low growth
high-tax economy is working for working
people
my Minister Mr Mr Speaker because of the
action that we've taken on the national
living wage at record levels on pension
on Universal Credit and the generous
cost of living payments just yesterday
Mr Speaker almost 8 million households
receiving direct support from this cost
of this conservative government we are
supporting working people but just this
week Mr Speaker in The Other Place we've
seen his party side with protesters and
with picketers he should actually try
backing working people
[Applause]
plus sixteen hundred pounds worse off
Mr Speaker I'm genuinely fascinated to
know does he really think that
everything's fine or is he just clueless
about life outside of his bubble
[Applause]
Mr Speaker because because of the
actions that we have taken well let's
just go over it a single mother a single
mother working full-time on the national
living wage this year will get 1 300
pounds more support from this government
a working couple on low income with two
children will get 1 800 pounds Mr
Speaker that's what delivering for
working Britain looks like but if he has
any actual ideas for the economy he
should say so because all I hear from
the party opposite it's more spending
more borrowing higher inflation higher
interest rates it's the same old labor
party
let's go
this is Mr 24 tax Rises
[Applause]
just his refusal to take any
responsibility for the damage they've
done the crashed economy the hit to
living standards it's also he refuses to
take the action that's needed he could
stop the handouts he's giving to oil and
gas giants he could scrap his beloved
non-dom status
he could put that money back in the
hands of working people and get the NHS
back on his feet that's what a labor
government would do
why doesn't he
[Applause]
Mr Mr Speaker the record was clear look
at it right now record record numbers of
people in work Mr Speaker record numbers
of people in work inequality no lower
the number of people in poverty lower
those in low pay the lowest numbers on
record Mr Speaker he talks about this
London thing I think he's already spent
the money that he claims he's raised on
five different things Mr Speaker because
it's the same old labor party they're
always running out of other people's
money
Mr Speaker
oh
had enough last week I'm certainly not
having this continuous noise so just be
aware that somebody will be going for
that cup of tea today prime minister Mr
Speaker he calls it this non-dom thing
let's be honest about what his reviews
status means it means that at every
possible opportunity he has voted to put
taxes up on working people while at the
same time taking every possible
opportunity to protect a tax avoidance
scheme that helped his own finances
why is the prime minister telling people
across the country that their taxes must
go up so that his can stay low
[Applause]
to these the very wealthiest pay more
tax and the poorest pay less tax under
that today than an under any year of the
last Labor government Mr Speaker we've
also boosted the national living wage
boosted Universal Credit and pensioners
but Mr Speaker the rank hypocrisy of it
as we saw as we saw last week when it
comes to his own special pension scheme
I mean and I I said I said it last week
but I'll say again it's it's literally
one law for him and a tax rise for
everybody else
[Applause]
speaker
here's the difference odd scrap his
pension giveaway whether it affected me
or not
he refusing he refuses to scrap the
non-dom status that benefits him and his
family this I can see why he's attracted
to this non-dom thing
this prime minister is so removed from
the country that he boasted that he
didn't know a single working-class
person
so insulated from reality that he
proudly told a Tory Garden Party how
he'd moved money from poorer areas I'm
added it to rich ones
so out of touch that he looked at a
petrol pump and a debit card like
they've just arrived from Mars
under that he smiles his way through the
cost of living crisis while putting
other people's taxes up is there any
wonder he doesn't have a clue how food
prices are hammering families across the
country and is it any wonder that under
him people are paying more and more are
getting less and less
just we'll just look at what's happened
just in this just in this week Mr
Speaker where the labor party have put
themselves on Monday in the other place
they decided to side with extremist
protesters to yesterday they sided with
polluters Mr Speaker
[Applause]
and tonight
tonight and tonight we will see them
siding with the people Smugglers Mr
Speaker I
whilst we're in the business of sending
back the 1 000 illegal migrant from
Albania Mr Speaker we're delivering cost
of living payments to millions of
households just yesterday and today
we've announced we put 20 000 more
police officers on the street
s we're siding with the British people
Mr Speaker that's what the conservative
government does
[Applause]
to go goulburn Urban District Council
wrote to the government about the urgent
need for a bypass for my constituency of
Lee 40 years ago the central section of
that bypass the otherly way was
constructed but to this day the bypass
remains unfinished leading to daily
gridlock in some areas of the community
will the Prime Minister support my
proposals to complete the other leeway
and will he meet with me to discuss this
further so we can get Lee moving again
oh Mr Mr Speaker I commend my honorable
friends campaigning on this issue and I
know there have been a number of
proposals for Road improvements in this
area uh he will know that it's for the
local highways authority to develop
those plans but I know a meeting is
planned in June to move proposals
forward and I know he will take his
energy and enthusiasm for his campaign
to that meeting and I wish him well we
could do I said Peace spokesperson
stupid leader
thank you Mr Speaker can I ask the prime
can I ask the prime minister to outline
the safe and legal route available to a
child Refugee seeking to flee Sudan and
come to the United Kingdom yeah yeah
speaker as Outland earlier our priority
is
diplomats and their families which I'm
very pleased we were one of the first
countries to be able to do Mr Speaker
and since yesterday we've been
conducting a large-scale evacuation of
British Nationals
we have some of the largest numbers of
British Nationals on the ground and
rightly and I'm sure the whole house
will agree with me that it is reasonable
legal and fair to prioritize those most
vulnerable families particularly those
with elderly people in them medical
conditions but also children Mr Speaker
that's what we're in the process of
doing and I pay tribute to all those who
are making it possible leader of the SMP
but Mr Speaker to be clear and I think
everyone in the house is aware of this
children in Sudan are already dying now
whether it's a Tory slogan to stop the
boat sort of leave our slogan to stop
small boats we need some more Humanity
in this city rather than the race to the
bottom which we see here today so can I
ask the Prime Minister now that he has
confirmed that there is no safe and
legal route well he therefore confirmed
that it would be his government's
intention to detain and Deport a child
Refugee who flees Sudan and comes to the
United Kingdom Mr Speaker in fact
because of the effort
our a teams we've
we've said almost 250 million pounds in
humanitarian support in Sudan over the
past five years and Mr Speaker I
even does it always
actually this country has a proud record
of compassionately supporting those who
need our assistance just over the last
few years we have welcomed almost half a
million vulnerable people to our country
including many children and it's that
compassion that we want to make sure we
continue Mr Speaker which is why it's
precisely right that we make sure that
our system is not exploited by those
coming here illegally and that's what
our bill will deliver not to Luke Evans
Mr Speaker the lib Dem run Hinckley and
Bosworth Borough Council don't have an
up-to-date local plan
so that every day that goes past we have
speculative housing applications that
put pressure on the infrastructure like
GP surgery schools and roads now locally
the lib Dems say it's the 300 000
housing Target the government has yet
the lib Dems have a target of 380 000
houses
oh
so we're the Prime Minister change the
law to ensure that communities like
Burbage barwell markfield and Market
Bosworth get the infrastructure and
protection they need for the houses that
we need prime minister well Mr Speaker
honorable friend is right to point out
the hypocrisy of the local liberal
Democrats on this issue
and he's and he's is right to highlight
this issue locally because the new
infrastructure Levy does give local
areas the power to deliver the local
infrastructure that he supports and
wants for his area but also he's
absolutely right and point out the
importance of a local plan because it is
precisely that having a local plan is
what gives communities the power to
ensure that development in their area is
happening in the way that they want it
to and the council is failing in its
duty to do that for its communities by
not putting forward that local plan
there's several Roberts incredibly any
traveler wanting to go by train from
North to South Wales has to go via
England linking Wales north to south
would cost two billion pounds now the PM
talks about running away with other
people's money but his government is
depriving Wales for the tune of six
billion pounds by ruling that
north-south England rail Lynx like hs2
somehow benefit Wales will he plead
guilty to the great Welsh Train Robbery
Mr Mr Speaker is The Honorable lady
knows how transport it's handled in in
Wales and what I would say to her is
that we do always want to work
cooperatively with the Welsh government
see where we can deliver jointly for
people in Wales or actually investing
record sums in communities up and down
the up and down Wells through the
leveling up fund and the community
ownership fund we're happy to continue
those conversations many of those are
Transportation projects and I think
hopefully she'll join me in saying what
the people of Wales do not need is the
labor Welsh government's plan to ban all
building of New Roads
thank you Mr Speaker will the Prime
Minister back our local plans to reopen
our much-loved Morgan Hills College and
does he agree that Warwickshire college
group should negotiate the sale in good
faith and not resort to using public
money to sue our district council prime
minister well Mr Mr Speaker I thank my
honorable friend for raising this issue
I of course recognize the valuable work
that all colleges do in meeting local
skills need and very much welcome local
community groups working together to
regret address gaps in the way that her
local area is doing my understanding is
that the my honorable friendly education
secretary is in discussion with the
college and I know that my honorable
friend will continue making
representations to her Fabian Hamilton
Mr Speaker my constituent Ian Greenwood
tragically lost his 12 year old daughter
in a road traffic collision that should
never have happened Ian's now
campaigning for Leeds Vision zero which
aims to End Road deaths and serious
injuries by 2040. we really have to make
our roads much safer so will the Prime
Minister commit to giving local
authorities sufficient funding in order
to ensure that these vehicle collisions
can never take a young life again
Minister well Mr Speaker I'm incredibly
sorry to hear about the tragic lost of
Ian's daughter of course we should do
everything we can to improve Road Safety
I know actually at the moment that we
are doing an enormous amount and the
statistics show that is improving but
we're always happy to look at where we
can do more and I know the transport
secretary will look into the suggestions
raised by The Honorable gentleman
Roberts
speaker the village of north of Hall in
my constituency has about a thousand
residents last year north of all Hotel
on the edge of the village was bought
and there are now proposals to house 400
single male migrants in the building and
in shipping containers stacked around
the grounds
The Village has one small shop no
transport links and a Health Board in
complete meltdown
can the Prime Minister facilitate a
meeting for myself and some local
residents with the Home Secretary to
hear the concerns of the local residents
who are worried that the government just
isn't listening to them
Mr Speaker the uh The Honorable
gentleman raises exactly why we need to
take action because it's not right that
our local hotels in all our communities
are being used to such a degree to house
this legal Asylum Seekers not least
because it's costing the British
taxpayer something like five and a half
or six million pounds a day we want to
put an end to that and that's why we're
bringing forward legislation that will
enable us to swiftly detain and send
back those who should not be here but I
will make sure that he gets a meeting
with the immigration Minister as he
needs
figures out today show that their food
banks gave out a record number of meals
over the past year it's nearly three
million meals a million of which went to
children now the prime minister's
fortunate he's a wealthy man but all
these families want to be able to do is
to put food on their table to be able to
feed their own children without having
to resort to food banks does he think
that's too much to ask
[Applause]
Mr Mr Speaker as I've said previously we
absolutely do want anyone to have to
rely on a food bank but whilst there are
people who do use them I'm very grateful
to all of those who volunteer their time
to make sure that they are providing
their local communities we've put
substantial provision in place not least
uh infant free School meals and broader
free School meals which are helping
almost 2 million children but also last
year the investment in the holiday
activity and food program which provides
not just food but also activities
outside of term time and we'll continue
to do everything we can to help those in
low pay which is why we're raising the
national living wage to record levels
and I'm pleased to say that that those
living in poverty today is 2 million
lower than when we first came into
office
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
e-cigarettes were introduced as a stop
smoking device but they're remarkably
cheap brightly colored Vapes with
flavors such as unicorn milkshake bubble
gum and green gummy bear have removed
approved remarkably attractive to
children cooking them on a lifetime is
potentially harmful nicotine addiction
will my honorable friends meet with me
to talk about how work across government
departments can help to stop our
children becoming hooked on Vapes and
will be back my 10-minute rule bill for
Van disposable Vapes prime minister can
I um can I commend my honorable friend
for her work in this area I absolutely
recognize the concern that she raises
both on the environmental impact of
disposable Vapes but also their appeal
to children dhse have announced a call
for evidence to look at reducing youth
vaping including Vape appearance flavors
and marketing we've also been clear that
all electrical waste should be disposed
of properly and defra looking actively
at what changes in legislation might be
needed to ensure that The Vaping sector
foots the bill for the collection and
treatment of their used products UK Fox
from thank you Mr Speaker as we
celebrate the lives of Lily Savage and
Dame Edna beverage Turning Point you
okay are planning to protester a drag
Story Time Event in my constituency on
Saturday for the third time this year
these events are friendly inclusive
opportunities for children to hear a
story and learn about quality Turning
Point UK members by contrast seek to
intimidate our young people they share
misleading images on social media
implying the events are inappropriate so
will the Prime Minister condemn Turning
Point UK's attempts to spread hatred and
Division in my constituency and across
the country
yeah well Mr Mr Speaker I'm not aware of
the specific uh allegations The
Honorable lady brings to light but in
general we should treat everybody with
respect and understanding and compassion
Mr Speaker and people should be allowed
to gather and Associate freely uh within
the bounds of the law and Intuit but
when it comes to children as we've said
it's important that the material that
children are exposed to in classrooms is
sensitive and age-appropriate and that's
why we're reviewing the rhse guidance
currently James Morris thank you Mr
Speaker this uh year marks the 400th
anniversary of the publication of
Shakespeare's first folio and his plays
are not only a central part of our
national culture but many people around
the world see them as a Beacon of Hope
in darkest times I recently met with
Professor Natalia tokrut the director of
the Shakespeare Institute in Ukraine who
told stories of actors directors and
Scholars putting on Shakespeare plays in
air raid shelters in Ukraine is an
active Defiance against Russian
aggression and bombs so would the Prime
Minister agree with me that
notwithstanding The Sound and Fury of
domestic politics that in Shakespeare's
works we have a force for freedom in a
world often dominated by the brutality
and tyranny of oppressive regimes
I can't join my honorable friend and his
uh comments and and coincidentally uh
one of the first gifts that I gave
president zielinski was an old copy of
Henry V and so I think his comments are
well made and that's why we're training
and arming Ukrainian forces with the
equipment they need to push back Russian
forces and we know and I know the whole
house will join me in saying that the
people of Ukraine's Incredible strength
and inspiring bravery will ultimately
defeat tyranny
thank you Mr Speaker this month marks 23
years since the passing of the late
great Bernie Grant a former member of
this house and the founder of the UK
reparations movement in the UK in his
last prime minister's questions before
his death he asked for an apology to the
people of African descent living and
dead for our country's role in slavery
and colonialism but since then Prime
Ministers and heads of state have only
ever expressed sorrow or deep regret
these are not sentiments that are
befitting one of the greatest atrocities
in human history and there's been no
acknowledgment of the wealth that has
been amassed or the fact that our
country took out the largest loan it
ever has to pay off the slave owners and
not this enslaved so I want to ask the
Prime Minister today if he will do what
Bernie Grant asked all those years ago
what I have asked and what countless
others have asked since and offer a full
and meaningful apology for our country's
role in slavery and colonialism and
commit to reparatory Justice yes
no no Mr Speaker that what I think our
focus should now be on doing is of
course understanding our history in all
its parts not running away from it but
right now making sure that we have a
society which is inclusive and tolerant
of people from all backgrounds uh that's
something that we on this house are
outside of the house are committed to
doing and will continue to deliver but
trying to unpick our history is not the
right way forward and it's not something
that we will focus our energies on
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker the
Prime Minister will recall his visit to
rugby to see our great work in
delivering new homes and the new
community of Halton where one thousand
of six thousand homes in occupied but
regrettably
urgent care services at our local
hospital of Saint cross are not keeping
Pace with this growth and as a
consequence eighty thousand of my
constituents now live more than 50
minutes drive from a major a e unit may
I therefore invite the prime minister to
return to rugby to see for himself the
need to upgrade our Emergency Care
provision yeah
Mr Speaker it's absolutely vital that
people can access the LHS Services they
need particularly emergency care and
that's why we're investing an extra
billion pounds a dedicated funding to
support urgency urgent emergency care
services um honorable friend will know
that the specific provision is a matter
for local NHS Commissioners and
providers because plans for those things
need to be developed locally and take
into account the expanding needs of
local populations and I know that my
honorable friend will continue to engage
with his local NHS trust to ensure the
views of his constituents and
communities are well known and
adequately provided for Angela crawl
yeah yeah thank you Mr Speaker prime
minister every day I meet with
constituents struggling to make ends
meet food banks barely managing to meet
the demands households and businesses up
and down this country struggling to meet
their energy bills yet the bank of
England has already announced that it is
likely to increase interest rates once
again which will affect the poorest most
and high-cut mortgage rates once again
does the Prime Minister after 13 years
of conservatives government agree with
the bank of England's Chief Economist
that the poorest should just accept
being poorer
prime minister Mr Speaker we are doing
an enormous amount to support those who
most need our help with the cost of
living and some of the pressures
particularly on energy bills that they
face that's why we made a decision to
tax the windfall profits of energy
companies and use that money to help pay
around half of a typical family's Energy
bill that is support worth fifteen
hundred pounds it applies across the
United Kingdom and on top of that there
direct payments going to the most
vulnerable families in our society just
yesterday the first of those payments
was put out 300 pounds the first of
three payments and that went to one in
three households Mr Speaker including
many in Scotland and that is our
conservative government delivering for
the people of Scotland and making sure
they have the help they need to manage
some of the pressures that they're
facing it's Robert Goodwill
in Yorkshire we say you should judge a
person by the company that they keep
so what will the prime minister's view
of an individual who can not only bear
to spend more than 10 minutes in the
presence of Vladimir Putin but refers to
him as a dear friend
prime minister
well Mr Mr Speaker I think our views on
President pluton are well known his
illegal war in in Ukraine has caused
Untold misery for many people it's
caused a humanitarian crisis and is
still ongoing in defiance of
international condemnation and sanction
Mr Speaker we will do everything we can
to bring those responsible for war
crimes to Justice continue to support
Ukraine militarily and make sure that we
can support them all the way to Victory
Mr Speaker I know that the whole house
is united in wanting that outcome so
George Howard
thank you Mr Speaker given the chronic
lack of capacity in the NHS
the Prime Minister will be aware that
Community pharmacies can help deal with
minor illnesses
but there is a problem on average 10
pharmacies close every month in England
will he take
urgent action to prevent further
closures and commission a properly
funded first Pharmacy first service for
minor illnesses
Mr Speaker a rare agreement between the
honorable gentleman myself that I am a
wholehearted champion and believer in
the role that Community pharmacists can
play and we want to make sure that they
can they can do everything to ease some
of the pressures in Primary Care is
something that we're actively talking to
the sector about we'll always continue
to do everything we can to support
Community Farms is I know firsthand how
respected they are in their communities
and I think they can do more for us over
time
okay Mr Speaker after a 15 year break
wrexham association football club is
will the Prime Minister join me in
congratulating everyone at the club
including the loyal supporters and the
owners Ryan Reynolds on Rob mceleni and
does he agree that wrexim is no longer a
neglected place but quickly becoming a
jewel in the crown of the United Kingdom
uh well Mr Speaker can I uh join my
honorable friend in congratulating
everyone at wrexham from the owner to
the players to support us and everyone
in the community it's been an incredible
ride we've all enjoyed watching them and
we wish them every future success Mr
Speaker and I join with her and say they
are indeed a jewel in the crown and she
deserves enormous credit for championing
them in this place
we're here thank you Mr Speaker after an
investigation ordered by the Prime
Minister himself I've senior
conservative MP was found guilty of
bullying found guilty of behavior that
was persistently aggressive and
intimidating the MP in question then
attempted to blame his victims and the
whole string of conservative MPS queued
up to defend him suggesting that his
conduct was not only acceptable but was
actually good to management practice
what did it say about the prime
minister's own values that it's done
nothing to distance himself from those
comments
prime minister
this this Mr Speaker when formal
complaints were made I rightly initiated
an independent investigation and as soon
as it reported uh action was taken
that's the right thing to do to follow
due process and then let the process
Play Out Mr Speaker but I do think it is
it is somewhat odd to be getting
lectures on values right now from the
SNP
thank you
that completes prime minister's
questions those please leave